[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH PAN: I was part of the
PIIRS Global Seminarsprogram
and I visited France in
the French theater class.
This photo is very
vibrant, and that's
how I would describe the
experience in France.
Every play that we went to
was a unique play in its own --
very colorful.
You know, the sound, the
French language, the culture --
everything is encapsulated
in this one photo.
Theater is something
that I didn't
think I was comfortable with.
It's all something
that’s very overwhelming.
But I think being in
a different community
and trying to explore something
new with other students that
are also trying to
do the same thing --
it's really refreshing.
And it gives you a foundation
to learn new things.
And that's what I loved
about my experience
with the Global Seminar.
ALEX FORD: Haiti has always
been near and dear to my heart.
And so for my senior
thesis, I looked
at transnational
identities, which
span the borders between
Haiti and America.
But also part of
my senior thesis
is a film based on
the story of when
I went to work in Haiti
after the earthquake
back in my early
years of high school.
When I look at the photo,
I see some joy in it.
You know, I see light.
You know, there
are clear waters.
You see the shadow on
the floor of the ocean.
And, to me, says
despite whatever
circumstances there are,
despite whatever hardships they
may face, there is still
a sense of happiness.
There's still a
sense of resilience.
There's still that
culture that bleeds
through them no matter what.
The goal of my photo
in this is to change
the narrative of Haiti.
You know, it's not what we see
generally or what we perceive.
I don't know.
They're still smiling.
And I think that's kind
of what's important.
ANNA MARSH: Princeton has
a really incredible program
called the Bridge
Year Program that
enables incoming
freshmen to spend
nine months in one of five
cities across the globe.
I was really excited
about Salvador, Brazil,
where I could work with an
urban gardening organization
and pursue a previously
established interest
in sustainable agriculture,
the environment, and also
community service.
And I was able to
explore the city
and get to know other
aspects of life there.
A couple other
Princeton students and I
got to know this
man, named Georgie,
who was an instrument creator.
Through this musical
and creative lens,
he forgets about a
lot of other things
that are going on
in a way that can be
very positive and productive.
But you're in the
presence of someone
who is so invested and
absorbed with their passion.
In his kitchen setting,
he's almost forgotten to clean.
He's forgotten to cook.
And it's as though
the only sustenance
is the beat of his drum,
the strum of his guitar.
It's just him and the music,
which was a cool experience
to be there.
YASH HUILGOL: One of
the many considerations
I had when I got to Princeton
was my interest in doing
some sort of
international experience
and get a chance to
be exposed to a pretty
different academic
environment than Princeton.
So what made this
photo, I think,
particularly exciting
was it not only
had a very important
national element
to what it means to
be a British person.
It also had a lot
of implications
of being a visitor in the U.K.
Getting a chance to see
the British people just
get completely excited
about this giant bonfire,
all these fireworks
for Guy Fawkes Day--
it's just such a
different experience.
In the U.S., you
wouldn't necessarily
be celebrating an effigy
going up into flame
and having like a huge bonfire.
So getting a chance to see that
just takes me back to not only
the different traditions
that go on abroad,
but also the celebrations
that continue from basically
the 1700s to present.
One thing about study abroad,
which is just phenomenal,
is you get a chance to
see things for real.
To be a part of this crazy
experience was something,
I think, that this
picture represents.
[MUSIC PLAYING]